el Gear Five es ridículamente poderoso
después de que se nos revelara que la
fruta de Luffy es en realidad la
jitomamimo de lonica queda preguntarse
qué tan fuerte es el Gear Five de Luffy
partiendo de que prácticamente resucitó
con este poder Luffy gana habilidades
increíbles como Modificar el entorno
convertirse en un gigante aún más grande
que el mismo kaido y agarrar rayos con
la mano limpia lo que lo vuelve tan
fuerte como para aventarse madrazos con
kaido uno para uno según la serie El
Poder real de la fruta es convertir la
imaginación de su usuario en algo real
claro el problema es que Luffy no lo
sabe Él sigue creyendo que es un humano
de goma y es por eso que aun después del
despertar sus habilidades siguen siendo
de goma pero si Luffy llegase a
enterarse de la verdadera naturaleza de
su fruta Según esto él podría ser
básicamente lo que le dé la gana si es
más fuerte que kaido eso ya es debatible
pero no hay ninguna duda de que